hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to inside now we just
washed up on a beach and my throat is
feeling a little bit tested because I've
been recording a lot today in
preparation for this trip but I think it
can hold out till the end of this game
so I don't know exactly where we are I'm
getting kind of vibes from Dishonored do
you remember the last level of
Dishonored when you approached the
island
no spoilers really but kind of that vibe
into the destitute solitary land that it
is now there's gonna be anything to do
with it
Boosh whoa [ __ ] oh god ow ow wha how are
you alive after that you've fallen from
others in different universes and died
cuz this is a multiverse theory where
you've died a million times over but it
never seems to have affected her oh it's
too heavy
oh god okay little old me can't do it so
I gotta find some healthy helper 10 to
help me along I don't know where I'm
gonna find a help you yell pretending
but wow what is that whoa that's huge
well that doesn't make any sense this
place was a fortress how is there just
all this stuff the structures in this
game are just enormous and what is the
thumpy
who the hell is dumpy humping that was a
complex hump thump I don't appreciate it
what is this what am i hump thumping
here this one just doesn't move okay oh
god the hump tops are given more erratic
than ever before
Oh what does this do gosh nineteen oh uh
still wondering about the Whoopie humps
yeah that's gotten into full-on whomp
mode some [ __ ]
let me put my ear to it Oh God okay so
that's bizarre but apparently that needs
quite a few able-bodied people maybe not
able minded people but able-bodied
indefinitely what does this do
oh we're going up okay
I'm yelling timber hurt I guess I'm
going up I'm yelling crap myth rabid I'm
yelling rapid huh okay anyway so what
else can we do ah that doesn't help me
at all that's probably a return path so
there's nothing over there then there's
nothing over here huh
okay now we're onto something damn this
place so big hello hi you're part of the
collection of people that I need don't
mind while I push you off into oblivion
no I can't do it what am I supposed to
do with this connects eclis am I
supposed to be able to get magical
powers that's gonna make me command
these people on the fly I'm not I gotta
get one of those helmets permanently
installed in my boy I'm okay with that
the only thing that I'm sad about this
serious is that I haven't been able to
make nearly as many dick jokes as I
usually enjoy
cuz I mean I have a certain standard of
what a quota a quota of dick quote joke
so a dick quota - quota North Dakota
South Dakota dammit I can't have that
never won anyway so that's the stupidity
on my friend it's getting very late like
I said I've been reporting a lot so my
mind is a little bit loopy than it has
been in the past whoa hello hi okay
there's a rope there and I imagine
there's probably more people over here
can I hold it I can't pull any of this
stuff I'm just a child I'm supposed to
be able to do any of this okay so I
can't do that either
I can't do much of anything around here
I need people I mean I need 19 more
people than I've got but I need more
people so I need people to be able to
help me to do that so I I guess the good
thing is I'm kind of getting a lay of
the land before I actually do it and
again I don't know what the thumpy humps
are but I imagine it's a big wampie hump
Urton boo what is this hello okay but I
gotta have some method to control these
things because otherwise it doesn't mean
anything
hmm okay oh hi how you doing okay so
that's a thing so I'm gonna get that
it's gonna fall down and then it's gonna
be permanently imbued inside my brain
hopefully slip loose yes dive headfirst
into the random murky waters I'm going
down oh boy I hope I have enough air for
this there we go okay so where we go now
further down can do you got it bubs you
got to rub it up bubs bubs in the tub
okay
whoa what is that can I climb up this
yeah I can what is that just fascinated
by more than anything like that's
another thing that makes this game
really cool I'm just kind of fascinated
by everything that I see like it's just
constantly really like it's like I
always want to see the next big thing I
haven't been bored yet at all with the
game and that's a car that's like a
quality of a good game like solidly good
game or good anything for that matter
like good anything that just keeps you
engaged and makes you want to know more
oh yeah I knew it I knew it they caught
me oh they caught me cool that's awesome
they're gonna come with me now okay you
come with me now and we're gonna go pull
a big thing on the bobber and I'm gonna
can you get me up here hey wait I pray
to the heavens
save us okay hey up okay Whoopi do boo
thank you man these guys are good I have
truly become control master it's like
winning the original limbo when that
when the worm got in your brain and
things ain't do so good am done all
right so yeah but there's a little bit
better because now I have superpowers I
imagine for permanence ease oh come on
be careful man you're gonna get caught
up in things oh they're so creepy I was
about to say adorable but it's just
really bizarre the way the thing got a
mash up against me they're just so oh
they just want to serve that's so nice I
suppose not really but we're gonna go
pull a thing come with me we got more
work to do I'm gonna call you
Geoffrey Billy Samwise Marshall and
Vladimir he's in the back he's a little
slower than the rest but that doesn't
matter so Geoffrey Billy samurais
Marshall and Vladimir you guys come help
me pull this big old honking thing well
oh oh don't look at me Vladimir get in
there well
oh I know I know I know okay so what
okay I'm gonna leave that there and then
I'm gonna get them to pull me up on this
thing Wladimir get back here
Deborah Billy Sam wasn't Marshall always
so good and like ready to go whenever I
need them to but you have not been
meeting expectations so wait a minute
ah there we go okay so what does this
meet oh I get it I need to fill it with
something
Oh what is that up there oh man so I
need to fill it or I need to get inside
of it hey did you guys push that back
what'd you push that back do I got a
what do we gotta do here
I'm guessing it rolled back so I guess I
got to pull this really far and then
quickly get up in that thing and then do
the thing all right hurry hurry hurry
okay let me up let me up up up up up
okay wait it's unmoving then why did it
move why did it move from where it was
before Oh cuz they're pushing it they're
literally walking it over oh okay
ah that makes sense come to me Geoffrey
Billy Santosh Marshall and Vladimir okay
I get it now I hate happened the smart
one
Ibuki okay Oh with all my haboos keep
ours I'm gonna go somewhere can I get up
this thank you oh they're gonna be so
lost without me they're gonna be so
scared do I don't want them to be skewed
about me I hope this doesn't ruin it
we're getting water on this really
bizarre mind-control device doesn't do
anything bad for me yeah so far so good
ah hello why are you up there how did
you get up there
let me boost this out of the way this is
gonna be a humid umph oh it's gonna be
oh it's gonna jump me so good
uber that did nothing that did nothing
hey you guys you lazy ass bags get out
of there maybe if I'm not standing on it
it'll be a little bit better
hey no that ain't it so wait a minute
something's something's funky maybe I
got to pull this box on it I don't know
why that would be a thing let's try it
go for gold
hey that's a heavy-ass box okay maybe if
I'm standing maybe I'm gonna break this
thing if I pull this put this on here
stand on the box let's go for gold damn
that sucks oh I know what I need to do I
need to launch it then put the box
underneath it it'll break the box hey
who is the smart one now oh oh good
thing they avoided me they're so good at
what they do and they must have some
semblance of autonomy if they can get up
on their own it's got to be a thing that
they do come along I don't have the
patience to name all of you or the
memory with which to remember them John
Jeffrey Jamison John deafer Jamison
Jeffrey Billy Sam Oliver any name's
Jeffrey John John Jacob Jamison John
Jacob Jamison Jeffrey Billy Sam wasn't
Marshall John Jacob Davis and Jeffrey
Billy Sam wasn't Marshall and Vladimir
can't forget about Vladimir Vladimir my
biologically related son
I have proof for that or else I wouldn't
believe it but Jeffery Jacob Jamison no
no John Jacob Jamison John Jacob Jamison
Jeffery Billy Sammis marshal this is not
very important why am I worried about
these stupid-ass names I don't know no
no no I make tasks for myself to keep my
memory engaged throw me huzzah huzzah
haha
all right thank you John Jacob Jameson
definitely Sam wasn't Marshall okay do I
need to go oh no I can I can lift the
door to the left first and then I can go
up get those guys on the right or maybe
they can launch me up above maybe that's
the thing they can do because they must
have some self-preservation thing
because their knob viously not gonna
they're not gonna do anything that's
gonna like actually kill them so they
kind of just do their own thing until
they could do a point where they can no
longer do that thing right isn't that
right John Jacob Jamison Jeffrey Billy
Sam wasn't Marshall and Vladimir
Vladimir still in the back I know he's
there all right wherever you is you're
gonna join our party gonna be fun on a
bun
ha ha there's so many of us hey how's it
going join us join us what uh uh-huh
what uh uh it's okay can you guys launch
me
hey that Nam ain't it I did not think
that was gonna make it
whoa that that's that's weird why were
you in that cart why were you guys so I
got it I got a crisscross this they're
not having a fun ride they're very upset
about this but I got a Criss crosses and
they have enough momentum to a [ __ ]
that probably hurt sorry sorry boys it's
probably that light
ah [ __ ] very close almost got it boys
almost got it almost got it don't worry
about it
Oh God I'm not gonna name you [ __ ]
probably gonna name the [ __ ]
here baby I did it we yeah okay well
they're all dead okay so we got John
Jacob Damon son Jeffery Billy Sam was
marshal and Vladimir I'm gonna name you
was there three of three of them um
Larry Moe and Curly just to make it easy
on my says we got Larry Moe and Curly
John Jacob Jamison Jeffrey Billy
Sandwich Marshall and Vladimir they
can't forget about lemon so Larry Moe
curly John Jacob Jamison Jeffrey bill
exam eyes and Marshall come with me boys
oh man I didn't know I was gonna be such
a involved adoptive father for all of
you guys Larry Moe curly John Jacob
Davidson Jeffrey Billy sandwich Marshall
and Vladimir cannot forget about who
here oh god I hope I don't having to
name any more of these [ __ ] I'm not
gonna be able to do it my brain has a
limited capacity for names I can't even
remember names of people that I meet so
how can i name remember the names of
Larry Moe curly John Jacob Davis and
Geoffrey Billy Sam was a marshal and
Vladimir all right so we're almost there
we just got to go up a little farther
and you [ __ ] are gonna help me
launch into another area now was there
anybody to the left I can't remember if
there's anybody might as well go Jake
come on Larry Moe curly John Jacob Davis
and Jeffrey bill examine some more shul
there anybody over here ah there are so
if we push you off what's that gonna do
that this is not gonna end well sorry
that sounded bad I don't think they
survived that I don't know how they
could Larry Moe curly John Jacob
Davidson Jeffrey Billy Sandwich Marshall
and Vladimir are murderers there gosh
darn bloody murderers I can't believe it
okay so you guys grab on to me don't
fail me please no no no no no no come on
come on don't be silly [ __ ] okay
thank you wait for me Larry Moe curly
John Jacob Davis and Jeffrey Billy
sandwich Marshall are you alive no
you're dead you're Vera dude so what
have you got it whoa [ __ ] I don't know
what keeps thumping on that yum per
board of everybody abandon this place
wait so there's no point in coming up
here then that one's dead you okay oh oh
ah maybe ah ah we don't need a live body
we don't need live bodies oh that's sad
it's sad that this kid understands the
reality of the situation oh man maybe
those other guys died and we just got to
drag their limp dead bodies
are they even alive that's another
question are they even considered live
creatures I mean to me Larry Moe curly
John Jacob Davidson Jeffery Billy
sandwich Marshall and Vladimir maybe not
Vladimir but you know they're there they
mean a lot to me I get them oh they're
dead
Oh yep they're there oh did you survive
that holy crap you guys are sprang my
goodness all right
so Richard Rick Randy Larry Moe curly
John Jacob Jamison Jeffery Billy Santos
Marshall and Vladimir Richard Rick Randy
no Rick Richard Rick Randy Richard Rick
Randy Larry Moe curly John Jacob Jameson
Jeffrey Billy's hand was a marshal okay
huh okay
so Richard Rick Randy Richard Brook
Randy Larry Moe curly John Jacob
Davidson Jeffrey Billy Sam was Marceline
Vladimir
come with me come with me follow me oh
they're not following me all right bye
boys
bye Richard Rick Randy whoa [ __ ] what is
that what is that
holy [ __ ]
whoa it's nuts
what is that that's so cool oh god I
should have done better
oh my dad that is insanity that's so
cool what is that what's doing that's so
cool I love it oh [ __ ]
EDD dee dee dee dee dee dee dee dee dee
dear good they think they have stow
hello it's good thing they have things
set up like this very helpful tip is
okay oh man I'm gonna miss Rick
Richard Rick Randy John Jacob Jameson
Larry Moe curly Jeffrey Billy sandwich
Marshall they were my best boys what are
you doing man why would anyone even
bother making machinery in this area
okay so I gotta time this no I gotta
stop this right yawn dur okay so that
gives me enough time to climb up a bit
cuz apparently that that pulse is just
gonna blast the liquid off of my bones
but only the liquid literally only the
liquid oh boy
okay here we go I gotta find out what's
gonna happen when that happens but oh
god ah it blasted the liquid off of my
bones I didn't know that that was gonna
happen that way but Wow
so I can do this differently so we're
gonna up that bad
oh that bad okay so I gotta figure out
another way to do this so if I crank the
yank they're like usual get by here huh
Badou now I'm super intrigued now I am
incredibly intrigued as to what in the
hell is going on in this world it is so
cool okay so there's no other way to go
down this except oh oh that was close
one so there's no other way to go down
this except for utilizing this thing so
maybe I can make it all up in one chunk
but that needs to be there I don't think
I can make it all the way up the ladder
without it maybe I can plan for okay I'm
planning for it yeah okay that'll work
woo okay yeah the music is confirming
that I did something relatively smart
okay so by the time I get down there
should be another blockade don't try to
hit me debris I've got my brain juices
flowing okay so I had time this
so I'm gonna crank that then yeah there
we go there we go there we go oh I'm
getting in I know what I'm doing yeah
what does this do yeah oh that's no oh
god oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
wait oh those things aren't real those
are test dummies or something okay we're
fine
whew like I got flown that guy got
flewed [ __ ] ah I got blasted okay so why
did I open those windows did those
windows need to be openness the question
maybe I can drag this with me
okay I can drag this okay that's good
this is awfully handy I like this okay
so that's as far as it goes right there
oh wow
hello and so fascinating whoa I did not
know that was that how that worked okay
I did not forget all right okay all
right okay okay okay all right so I
should have paid attention that the
railing is more than just a guide it was
a brace okay so we're gonna hold this
right here we'll here oh boy okay now
we're gonna go go go go go go go go go
go very close on you hello Wow okay you
need to be a little more protective of
me you're being a bit of a douche all
right so what is this thing
yeah what kind of purpose is this it's
not even grabbing anything okay I think
I go down I'll go down it's gonna go
down it's gonna go down right about here
yeah okay go go go go go go yeah okay
goodbye I forgot that it was gonna do
that thing I was that close to the end
I'm a [ __ ] bag I'm back oh [ __ ] Louie
okay
wait so I don't need to not trying to a
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] oh so close okay so I just need
to drop down right as the pulse is going
but I was trying not to go back so I
knew what I needed to do it dude help
you and haboos key okay and how about
key okay so we're good we're good we're
good and we're good okay man this poor
kid got what this kid has had to endure
and it's like some electromagnetic pulse
as well so like who who would build
machinery here I think we're out of it
I think we're officially out of it okay
this is good man who would build
anything out here unless that wasn't
here to begin with but then why would
still stuff still be running why would
they still have like this kind of
quote-unquote personnel with the zombie
mannequin type people no no there's so
many questions I don't have any answers
good bad good bad bad good I have no
idea
good bad maybe good maybe good how far
down can we go Oh waiting good dad damn
it
damnit and oh that's not good
how do I get out of here through here
left I think oh boy oh boy how do I get
out of here how do I get out of here how
do I get out of here there's really no
option how do I get it oh opening that
okay going going going going see the
light go towards the light light is good
light is good okay without saving grace
for this kid that wasn't there you would
have an utterly boner owned man I want
to know what that energy source is I
want to know so badly I want to know
we're gonna find out in the next steps
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always we'll see you in
the next video bye bye
take a look